tyrique hill absolutely tear it up
against tampa bay
is tyrion kill the fastest player in the
league tyrek
not only is he the fastest player in the
in the league he's the fastest person
i've ever
i've ever seen in my life the things he
do uh
the kind of energy he has um i've never
seen anything like it
have you covered him one-on-one in
practice i've covered him
a bunch actually in practice we've done
one-on-one drills um i probably say he
usually wins
[Laughter]
what's what's the harder matchup though
deal with tyrek's speed or
dealing with kelsey's size oh man it's
kind of like pick your poison
you know because you know not only is
tyrique hill
fast you know and then patrick arm can
kind of match his speed
but patrick and kelsey they're just like
on one accord
like they kelsey can run any route and
turn around the ball is like his chest
it's just
i probably say pat mahomes and travis
kelsey is like an unguardable
combination what does that do for your
defense that you get to play
against this offense i think you build a
lot
you know going against our offense the
speed
uh the personnel uh the different
motions the adjustments the
communication you have to go through i
probably say
our offense plays a big part uh you know
in preparing us
you know for the season
aaron are you seeing anything different
on film that kyler is able to do this
season that he wasn't able to do last
season
you can just say he's playing more
confident um feeling
look more a little bit more comfortable
being in his second year so
uh he's playing better football than he
was last year so i mean
he got some good guys around them that's
helping him as well so
um you know we got our hands full but
you know we prepared for the challenge
to be ready
aaron donald talking about the task of
chasing around kyle murray one of the
most elusive quarterbacks in the nfl
show me something time peter for week
13. i have a trivia question for you if
you get it right get the first pick
which quarterback is aaron donald sacked
the most times in his career
uh russell wilson
there are the horns the horns no they're
the horns
you are correct sir you get the first
pick in the show me something draft
you didn't ask me how i knew that how do
you know that
no one else in his division he is he's
played regularly other than russell
wilson
every time the rams have played the
niners since
or the rams that played the seahawks
since aaron donald has been in the
league
russell wilson's been the quarterback it
was that fantastic
power of deduction that i possess
[Laughter]
well well well done well done and for
that all you get
is first pick no prize no trophy no
money just first pick
look show me something kyler murray and
look i i'm like i'm in the kyler murray
fan club just like everybody else
but you know after the
uh you know the hail murray you know
he's had less than impressive
performances you know basically against
uh seattle and against new england he
now gets the rams at home
and the reason i say show me something
this week and why he's number one on my
list
is that you have to figure that jalen
ramsey
is going to do a lot to he has been used
all over the map by the rams on defense
this year
he's even been used in the slot he's
been used back
sort of as almost a roaming safety at
times
so i expect him to be used a lot on
deandre hopkins
and that is going to mean whether it's
christian kirk
andy isabella you know he's gonna
kyler murray is gonna have to find a
plan b this week
and so this is a huge game for
uh the cardinals playing at home and so
show me something kyla murray
good news for kyle murray he fully
participated in practice on thursday
he's got that shoulder injury that
happened a couple of weeks ago in the
thursday in that game
against the seattle seahawks hasn't been
the same guy since the hail murray and
and i still feel like the cardinals
thought they won something like they
they got a level of euphoria that it
took them a while to come down from and
go back to reality
and the reality is their own two since
then and clinging
to their playoff lives in the nfc baker
mayfield
show me something for reasons we
discussed earlier in the program they
all apply
this is your opportunity if you beat a
great team
then we'll start believing you can beat
other great teams beat the titans
we'll take you very seriously next
weekend against the ravens and we will
look
at the browns as a team that maybe could
deliver the first loss to the pittsburgh
steelers in week 17 if the steelers
otherwise keep winning which
is a bit of a long shot but still the
browns have to beat a good team
before we think they can beat good teams
baker mayfield has to step up and play
well
against a good team and here's the thing
about the tennessee titans it's not like
they have
a great pass rush it's not like they
have a crippling defense
so yeah maybe mayfield could have a good
game that's what they're going to need
in order to show that they are truly
here
as a contender in the nfl peter
show me something jalen hurts look
you're going to get an opportunity
i will be shocked if you have one or two
or three snaps
in this game in green bay this is going
to be the time for
jalen hurts to show that he belongs
at least as a middle relief pitcher or a
spot starter
uh you know over the last five weeks of
the season
the eagles are counting on them the
eagles are counting on
some production on the out of the
quarterback position they haven't had
and look i'm making a jump here and i'm
making a guess here
but i believe that this is going to be a
jalen hurts opportunity week
so show me something show me something
derek carr it wasn't that long ago where
the shine around car was beginning to
approach the year that
he was a fringe mvp candidate
up until that thursday night game in
kansas city he was a serious short list
talking point mvp possibility had the
broken leg late in the year
raiders made it to the playoffs but
didn't last with their backup
uh they need derek carr to step up
after last week's debacle in atlanta and
it was truly
a debacle three lost fumbles and an
interception no passing touchdowns blown
off the field
a disqualifying moment as i said earlier
for the
las vegas raiders they need car to step
up and
and it should be easy they're not
playing the 85 bears here
but he needs to reestablish himself
quickly so they can go into the last
four games of the season forgetting
about what happened last week
you know mike this is going to be a
little bit of a surprise but show me
something phillip rivers
you know normally you would look at a
game between
indianapolis and houston with
indianapolis three
wins better and he would say ah you know
the colts have got this one
i'm not so sure over the last four weeks
since houston's buy the texans are three
in one
indianapolis is two and two we've had
some great moments from phillip rivers
and some not so great moments
phillip rivers was brought to
indianapolis to take the colts to the
playoffs
to ensure a spot in the playoffs
you can't be losing to the houston
texans
in a big division game in december show
me something philip rivers
my next one is still technically part of
week 13 even though it's four days away
show me something dez bryant
you're getting your chance you've wanted
it for several years now
you're going against the dallas cowboys
and the ravens desperately need a win
and they need that spark and if there's
ever going to be a spark from dez bryant
it's going to come on tuesday night
against the cowboys they should have
lamar jackson back from the covet 19
list
and the last time jackson and bryant
were on the field together bryant was
the leading
receiver among all wide receivers not
the leading receiver for the team
because of mark andrews but four catches
for 58 yards for bryant
let's see if he can be a difference
maker and let's see if he can provide an
emotional lift
for a ravens team that desperately needs
to beat the cowboys
on tuesday night peter
my last one mike is show me something uh
drew luck and look
i don't think that the denver broncos
are going to beat the kansas city chiefs
i don't know how you could think that
but what i am thinking
is that uh john elway walks into his
office
every monday and i'm sure at some point
during the week he closed his door
and he starts looking at tape of college
quarterbacks
and drew lock has it in his ability
in his presence in his own play
to stop john elway from drafting a
quarterback in the first round
next april it's on drewlock's shoulders
these are the kind of games the games
that you have no business
winning these are the kind of games
where you say to yourself
i am playing patrick mahomes this week
i'm playing in my hometown
i'm gonna show everybody i belong in
this league as a starter
and i will be a winning player
in the nfl if i was drew luck that's
what i would be thinking this week
and that's what i will be watching for
this week a 30 to 27 loss
or something like that but a loss that
he goes head-to-head with patrick
mahomes
and he shows john elway i don't want you
to be looking at the florida quarterback
the byu quarterback
the north dakota state quarterback i am
your
quarterback you know and continuing with
a theme that we've
been addressing as it relates to team
presidents who seem to have lifetime
jobs john elway
never accountable in denver because they
don't have an owner changing out coaches
changing out quarterbacks
he's the guy who's making these
decisions and they're not working and we
thought locke was going to be the guy
injuries and a level of ineffectiveness
that we didn't anticipate when we saw
him kind of
land on the scene last year remember
that upset win over the texans he's
doing the buzz lightyear stuff he's
having a good time he's a breath of
fresh air
we thought he was on track to be a
franchise quarterback he's got a lot to
prove
and what an opportunity to do it with a
sunday night
audience watching patrick mahomes tuning
in to see the chiefs and maybe being
surprised pleasantly by what they see
from drew lock last one for me
show me something daryl bevel you've
waited a long time for a chance to be a
head coach or the interim head coach of
the detroit lions this is your
opportunity this is your
chance and it's not just the artificial
interim head coach bounce that you may
get
against the chicago bears there's an
element peter of ding dong the witch is
dead
for the detroit lions and and uh there
could be some positive energy there
for bevel to harness and go into chicago
and extend their losing streak to six
games
and and and maybe look the lions aren't
done yet at four and seven
get to five and seven maybe finish at
500
maybe make himself a candidate down the
stretch even though i don't like what it
does
for the team next year but maybe win
enough games and make enough noise that
he gets taken seriously by the lions or
someone else
as a coaching candidate at some point
it's a great observation there will be a
little bit of the ding dong the witch's
dead
uh bounce from the lions i think
and look i don't think that there was
nearly uh the enmity in either
honestly in either atlanta or houston
that they're ha that there will be in
detroit uh
and both the atlanta falcons and the
houston
texans have played good
to very good football since their head
coaches were fired
so normally i think mike normally we
would say ah what good does it do to get
an interim coach
it just gives the fans their their pound
of flesh you know in firing the coach
but in two cases this year there have
been
great examples that firing the coach
after four or five games is a great idea
because it's worked in two places this
year
and that's not good news in a copycat
league where 2021 rolls around and if
teams struggle they may say hey it
worked last year for the falcons it
worked last year for the texans
let's go ahead and fire our coach and
peter for me the thing that really was
telling
in detroit when matthew stafford was
asked after the loss to the texans on
thanksgiving
about matthew about matt patricia's
status he said
that's not my decision if you want to
ask me about the game ask me about the
game
uh oh that was everything we needed to
know about what ultimately happened on
saturday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports